Welcome to the first unit of Online Introduction to Artificial Intelligence.
I will be teaching you the very, very basics today.
This is Unit 1 of Artificial Intelligence.
Welcome.
The purpose of this class is twofold:
Number 1, to teach you the very basics of artificial intelligence
so you'll be able to talk to people in the field
and understand the basic tools of the trade;
and also, very importantly, to excite you about the field.
I have been in the field of artificial intelligence for about 20 years,
and it's been truly rewarding.
So I want you to participate in the beauty and the excitement of AI
so you can become a professional who gets the same reward
and excitement out of this field as I do.
The basic structure of this class involves videos
in which Peter or I will teach you something new,
then also quizzes, which we will ask you about your ability to answer AI questions,
and finally, answer videos in which we tell you what the right answer would have been
for the quiz that you might have falsely or incorrectly answered before.
This will all be reiterated, and every so often you get a homework assignment,
also in the form of quizzes.
And then we also have video exams.
An AI program is called wetware, a formula, or an intelligent agent.
Pick the one that fits best.